vu d'allemagne est ce que les retraités
français ils font figure de privilégiés
ils font figure de privilégiés et les
retraités allemands aimeraient bien
avoir la même situation que les
retraités français et c'est pour ça je
dis très clairement a fait attention en
france à ne pas aller dans le même sens
la même situation qu'en allemagne parce
que c'est une catastrophe pour les
personnes âgées et il faut faire très
très attention à ce qui se fait cela ne
signifie pas qu'il ne faut pas faire de
réformes nous pensons aussi en allemagne
devoir faire des réformes dans le sens
que tous cotisent par exemple dans une
même retraite dans un même système
social en allemagne c'est une des choses
dont nous discutons en ce moment
justement pour pour aider les fonds de
retraite pour pour avoir des arrivées
est aussi nous disons très clairement
dans le spd que nous avons un régime
dans lequel jusqu'à un certain jusqu'à
environ 10000 euros de l'argent que l'on
ne gagne de revenus on paye
je ne sais plus combien de porc ce
pourcentage pour les retraités
ensuite c'est plafonné et nous disons
pourquoi est-ce que c'est plafonnier
pourquoi est-ce que le millionnaire
systèmes peuvent jouer à l'as muret
marche de oui pourquoi ce que le
millionnaire paye la même chose que
celui qui a dix mille euros donc on
verra si j'arriverai à mal et en
allemagne merci ce seront les mots de la
fin